Yeah.
[inaudible] everyone.
Welcome to toxic Google.
I'm Kevin Valic.
And today you guys know the two from the hit show on comedy central key and
Peele.
And they have their new film coming out on April 29th.
Kiana Keegan.
Hi Guys.
How are you doing?
Alright,
happy faces.
This is cool.
So good working environment.
Not nary a suit to be found.
I love.
So welcome.
So tell me about [inaudible].
Tell us about the film.
Okay,
so Keanu is,
it is a film,
a script,
a film from a script.
This is very rudimentary.
The way I'm going to be through this process.
You write characters using words,
there's words in the English language is on the,
okay.
So a,
a key and Peele writer named Alex Rubens and myself,
uh,
wrote this a few years ago with the idea that at some point someone would come
ask you for a key and Peele movie.
Um,
so we wrote,
uh,
the,
the most fun movie we could think of.
And it is this movie that,
uh,
we were originally inspired by like three Amigos and raising Arizona and uh,
true romance Zelman Louise Movies that had this heart that takes us through it
and putting our characters,
Keegan and my characters in this fish out of water scenario,
this,
this world of high stakes crime.
But we wanted to give them a reason that would,
uh,
ground this journey and make it,
make it feel real.
So we put a kitten with a do rag on as the centerpiece of the,
of the movie.
And eventually somebody caught on that this would be a good idea.
And it was new line cinemas and Warner brothers made the film for us.
Was the idea always to involve a cat?
It's,
it's,
we've a lot of people that obviously I've just seen the trailer,
but it's absolutely ridiculous.
And did it always involve a cat where is like,
let's make a comedy action movie?
Or what was kind of the genesis of that was actually the second one.
We wrote a draft of the script
but didn't have the kitten in it and then we realized,
you know what we,
I know we are the two most biggest box office draws of all time.
You do amazing business in Europe and Israel.
Say this goes to somewhere like Thailand where maybe the people don't know us as
well.
Put the cat in the poster,
boom,
signed,
sealed,
delivered.
We didn't expect that the kitten poster would just be,
it would be here as well.
We thought maybe we would.
Maybe we'd be on the poster maybe here in the states the case.
But I mean you can't really lose with a kitten named Keanu.
I mean,
you know,
just walking down the street and I wrote me.
He was like,
I knew,
you know what I mean?
So it was a kid,
the movie a good to go see this movie.
Yes.
This black people in the tomb.
We,
I had read that you actually didn't know about that.
He was actually working on the,
I didn't,
I was at work one day and he just,
he,
we were just at work and he came up and said,
I've been working on this thing with Alex and,
and know he,
he,
he's such a prolific writer.
I was like,
you know,
oh,
that's good.
Good,
good for you.
And he's like,
no,
it's kind of pretty much a movie.
It's a key and Peele movie for us.
And I was,
I was like,
oh,
he's like,
w w was going to do a table read on Friday.
And it was like,
Gee,
do you want me to be there?
And he's like,
yes.
Yeah.
Keegan,
I wrote a character for you.
It's a key and Peele movie.
And,
and I think that first draft that we read,
the draft I read,
we read at that table read,
didn't have the kitten in it.
Right.
That sounds right.
That was the first,
yeah,
that very first draft.
Yeah.
And it made it more having the kit and also they make kills about six birds with
one.
It's like a neutron bomb.
It kills about six birds with one stone,
which is a pretty weak neutron bomb,
but just,
just so,
but that's,
that's just stones.
Um,
this was a big,
that's just really just a big rock.
It's stone.
It's really not a lot of technology involved at all.
Um,
but um,
so the,
the kitten also serves to go,
I mean,
pets.
Pets are so close to our hearts and pets are our members of our families.
So it helps,
it helps justify a lot of things in the movie.
These two guys,
what,
what propels them.
The trigger that gets them into this fish out of water situation is that we got
to save the life of this innocent animal.
You know,
you had talked about working with Alex Rubens and Peter Atencio and you guys
have both worked with them pretty much all the way through with key and Peele.
So were they really the only choice?
Like you're directing it and you're writing it was that,
you know,
we,
the,
the writing of it started more of a passion project.
Let's see what,
let's see if we can make our,
our favorite key and Peele movie.
It was a SPEC script,
right.
There was commission.
They want to commission to write it.
Yeah.
It wasn't,
it wasn't,
it wasn't very official.
It was like,
hey,
we're kind of in this a position where we can sell a,
an actual movie at some point.
So that was,
that was that when we,
uh,
when they,
they decided they were going to make the movie,
um,
Peter was absolutely our first choice.
Uh,
we,
we've developed a real rapport with him and,
and he knows when to push us further and he knows how to rope us back in.
And he's also a master of genre.
I mean,
obviously if you look at our sketch show,
he's covered.
He,
he's done a short film in every genre of film imaginable.
And this in a,
in a,
in a way this is a genre film in that we wanted to point to some of those movies
we were talking about that,
that kind of early to mid nineties action comedy with substance in Heart where,
uh,
where the bullets hurt,
where the bullets are real,
let's Keagan says.
Um,
so,
uh,
yeah,
you have a lot of references like boondock saints and heat and
and I mean,
yeah and,
and to like things like boondock saints and reservoir dogs,
but then also more commercial stuff like speed and the movies that and movies
that hearkened to,
and even an earlier time like,
like Beverly Hills Cop,
it's the same thing.
Like the violence has to be
and you're still laughing hysterically and the,
and,
and nowadays what we just call that is,
is being,
is being grounded.
So it's just like keep it as grounded as possible.
I mean,
it's the most ridiculous thing you've ever heard of.
So let's try to keep it as real,
as had the acting,
be as real,
have the violence,
be as real as it can be.
And you guys have talked about,
you know,
where the name Caddo has come from and there's an obvious reference to it.
I mean,
we know who it's about.
Well,
I mean,
we know where the name came from galleries,
but it,
was there anything,
was there ever a different name for the film or for the cat?
There was a point where we talked about early on we talked about,
uh,
the title new New Jack Kitty.
Well Guy,
one guy grown back there and that's,
that's all we need.
That's one reason we just need one black guy to grown for validate is never
going to be the name of the movie.
Um,
but,
uh,
no,
as soon as we came up with the,
that the kittens name was Keanu,
it was that,
it was clear.
Keanu,
we,
we love the idea of giving the audience a taste and having their imagination go,
what the fuck was this Keanu business?
And,
and,
and hopefully that,
you know,
that,
uh,
people would,
there would be this word of mouth in this discussion that would help people
answer the question.
You know,
what's this Kiana movie?
That's the key and Peele movie,
who's can peel?
Oh,
well you don't know key and Peele will shit.
Look,
this is fucking substitute teacher,
you know,
so this,
the word of mouth would kind of help be a discussion.
Just like,
you know,
our sketches.
One of the great,
the great things about getting to work on our show.
It's this time where our ski,
you know,
we,
we make the perfect size comedy for the,
the era that we're,
we're,
we're making content for,
um,
where,
where people can share,
literally share our bits with each other.
And so the,
the,
the fan base of key and Peele is really,
one is a familial fan base.
You ought,
we always hear,
Yo,
my brother turned me onto your show and now he's not give it to my dad.
And my dad's now a fan.
And there's always this line
of,
uh,
of love that kind of comes with our fan ship.
So it's really awesome.
And can you talk about your beginnings of,
you know,
starting the way back from that TV and,
and keep you,
what made this work?
Like what made you guys say gout?
You're my writing partner.
Like I get like we get each other.
What was that?
What clicked?
Well,
all of it.
We met in Chicago in 2003 and m and a mutual friend of ours who was a member of
the writing staff,
it can appeal.
She,
she said you guys have to meet each other.
You guys raised in similar situations,
come from similar backgrounds,
see comedy in a very similar way.
And she made sure that we met.
And just serendipitously,
Jordan's Jordan was working at a theater in Amsterdam and English speaking,
Improv Comedy Theater in Amsterdam like you do.
And,
and they,
and they came to the states to visit us.
And so he was performing at the second city when I was,
and that's how we met.
But so really what it comes down to is that our training is the same.
Our training comes from the same place.
So we were speaking a similar language before,
before we even met.
So then we met and you,
so you add those two elements together,
having similar backgrounds,
similar point of views on the world.
It does,
it means something to be biracial in the world because you become this kind of
racial referee and you're looking at the world sometimes very subjectively,
but sometimes very objectively.
And that is what fed the,
the partnership is having the same nomenclature about how we do process or how
we do comedy.
That's the process of how we do comedy and,
and then also having a similar worldview.
So what influences did you guys have growing up and saying,
you know,
establishing your brand of humor and sense of comedy and you know,
that a lot of it is,
um,
uh,
we're both big fans of in living color.
And that's been a touchstone for us,
that television show,
which,
uh,
in a way have changed our lives comedically.
And the people that were,
was doing the comedy was amazing to see faces that look like our faces.
But in the midst of that,
another ingredient in the stew is,
I grew up in Detroit,
very close to Canada,
so I used to watch lots and lots and lots of British comedy and Jordan's very,
very well versed and enjoys British comedy.
So that,
that's in our comedy too.
But then also there are other other influences.
It's,
you know,
we would be disingenuous to say that we're not standing on the shoulders of Dave
Chapelle because to watch him,
it's like,
ah,
there it is.
That's what we're going for a little,
you know,
something in that solar system right there.
But on top of it,
you know,
Jordan's,
um,
what I've always loved is that you're a big fan of,
of Martin and I would love it if you'd just explain why you like Martin Lawrence
so much
are both why he,
why he likes Martin Lawrence.
I like Martin Lawrence doesn't to say you don't like to say I don't like him.
Um,
you know,
I wa I was right at that perfect age for def comedy jam and a,
um,
from Martin to come out.
What I loved about him.
He was,
he the,
the character that he played,
Martin Payne on his show was so flawed.
And I love playing flawed characters.
I love this idea.
It was kind of a,
it was kind of a new idea.
You know,
I grew up with Eddie Murphy of course,
and Eddie Murphy is like,
he is the guy who can get away with anything.
He's Eddie Murphy is bugs bunny.
He's the books on his back.
He never gets,
he never loses.
And he's always on top of the game.
And Martin Lawrence was,
he,
he was daffy duck who was always my favorite cause that's the guy who you know,
is,
has been put through it in trouble.
And,
uh,
the guy who brings about his own demise and humiliation.
And so I love the way that Martin as an African American,
uh,
played,
played that comedic archetype.
And it was,
it was this high status,
low,
low status that he would get what he deserved.
And,
uh,
he did it the whole time.
You love the character even though he's flawed.
And,
uh,
so yeah,
Martin and,
and you know,
and then in the same realm,
people like Richard Pryor,
Richard Pryor had no qualms about being the one who lost or no qualms about
telling stories about his life.
You know,
most people,
if most people,
most people who were raised in a whorehouse are probably not going to make that
be the front and center thing they're going to talk about and the comedy or,
or their life or ever mentioned to anybody ever.
Yet it was a big part of his,
uh,
of,
of what he did on stage and what he did in his life and what his work ethic was
in his worldview was.
But,
uh,
Richard Pryor,
it might,
to me the perfect comedic monster comedic machine is a cross between the actor
Peter Sellers and Richard Pryor.
If you mix them together,
that would be it.
But I mean,
all,
all the British stuff to Fawlty towers and Monte Python and you know,
uh,
Mitchell and Webb,
we just,
yeah.
Right.
So once you get the set,
you know,
for county,
was there a lot of room for obviously this library for like Improv,
like how did scenes shaped do multiple takes of the same thing with different
things,
trying different things and oh I have this idea for this.
Yeah,
that's,
that's where the experience we,
we've developed on our sh uh,
we had and the style we developed on our show came in handy and that,
that a shorthand with Peter,
uh,
because yeah,
that's exactly how we would do it.
We would do it any scene three or four or five times.
Once we have it,
you know,
uh,
in a sort of standard pass on it.
Then we go crazy for three and then we do one call a five k,
which means we just going for it and it's just,
Oh,
just do a fun run.
It's a fun one for us.
Can we have one for us,
Peter?
And he'd go,
ah,
no guys,
is it going to be 12 minutes long?
I said,
well,
my friend,
yes it will.
And a
12 minute takes guys,
why are turned into margin on it?
Check,
check,
check.
One,
two,
one,
two.
Um,
but the,
the thing that we've,
we found,
uh,
on a,
on our show is that whenever we're like on the cusp of laughing or breaking
ourselves,
like those moments leading up to that are gold and the audience doesn't even
necessarily know they went on,
not conscious to it to break,
but you can just tell when we're having fun,
when we're sending each other a little off balance.
So we were,
we try and get into that world.
Was there,
what was the hardest thing to shoot for you guys or the hardest thing to get
right?
You know,
a lot of that,
a lot of action.
I mean the,
it was very hot.
We were in New Orleans in the summer.
Whole thing was very hot.
Um,
there,
the,
the scene he's talking about,
we're,
we're in.
That was hair.
That might've been the toughest scene for some reason.
Yeah.
I mean,
we were there for,
I'm sure it was like a 12,
13 hour day and just literally the exhaustion of being tied up and,
and playing exhausted,
playing hurt and drained
and screaming and screaming and just screaming,
screaming,
screaming.
Yeah.
Every take Peter sometimes
a little bit more,
you know what I mean?
You know,
you know,
so yeah.
That was it.
Gotcha.
We're going to start taking audience questions.
If you guys wanna start lining up at the mic.
Um,
you know what,
you guys spent so many years on,
on key and Peele and it was awesome.
Um,
so what did you guys learn most from that show that you were able,
cause you did obviously mostly like sketch comedy,
so it's taking those little bits and now you're explaining it to a full feature
film.
So what were you,
what'd you learn from there that you're able to use in your feature length film?
Oh,
I was just going to say that,
you know,
any given scene in the movie has to have a beginning,
a middle,
an end.
And we had been doing all of these small,
tiny movies.
But the,
the,
so that,
that's what you,
that's what you can,
that's what you can glean from the shorter form.
The short form allows you to go,
well,
every scene should have a purpose.
Clearly there has to be a thread through the film and every scene has to have a
purpose serving the one story.
But then it also,
I think naturally makes you make,
every scene has a beginning,
middle and end so that the scenes are just going to go,
you're at the end and you move on to the next scene and you lose momentum.
And I'd like to think that we've manufactured a film where the momentum keeps
building and building and building and building until it gets to its,
it's proper climax.
Gotcha.
And is there anything kind of in TV or film or,
or Broadway or whatever that you guys haven't done that you guys want to do?
Like what's next for you guys?
What do you guys,
um,
you know,
we're all sorts of different things.
I mean,
I'm a I d I just directed a movie.
I directed a horror film called get out that I'm very excited about.
I'm editing it right now and I love writing,
directing,
so I'll
take it.
Oh No,
it didn't come and come 10 at Tom's going to hurt later.
That's going to,
yeah,
that's going to catch on.
It's going to jump on your back at 3:00 AM.
That is going to be a really sloppy farming.
That's going to be,
that's how the by biology,
human biology works.
When you have a sneeze and it doesn't come later,
it's a fart.
So if it doesn't come out immediately it becomes a butt fart.
That's how it happened.
I mean,
uh,
but sneeze,
that's uh,
that's redundant.
I
had it all teed up.
My head butts niece knows at Google,
but fucks
more of this,
more of what I'm doing right now.
I'm more of these is what I want to do in my future.
Um,
no,
I,
I um,
I'm going to be doing a lot of theater,
a lot more theater in the future and a lot of classical theater.
That's my training.
Um,
my entire career has pretty much been a 19 year detour from,
from checkoff.
So,
which is what my plan was to do for the rest of my life.
Um,
so a lot more theater and a lot of the projects that are coming my way now that
I'm working around and picking our are dramatic projects.
It's lots of drama.
So,
yeah.
Awesome.
Hi there.
Thanks.
Thanks for coming.
This was fantastic.
Thanks for wearing those bitch and shorts.
It's what I have to say.
Got It.
Be as bro Ish as I possibly can.
So I think I'm succeeding.
And also thank you for liking Mitchell.
Um,
like he was David Mitchell and Robert Webb.
No one ever likes that.
Love Mitchell and Webb.
Mitchell and Webb.
Yeah.
Um,
I was wondering,
is there something that you like or dislike about like TV versus movie and vice
versa?
You know,
both as
actors,
there's a lot of waiting around and both,
which is,
you know,
sounds like a dream job in a way,
but there's this,
those strange stress involved.
Um,
the,
because
because you're,
you're putting yourself out there on the line and you're doing it with a,
in this collaborative process and if things go great,
you,
you get to celebrate it.
If they don't,
you're the face of the disaster.
Um,
so I,
that's present in both things.
I think the big difference obviously with,
with a film then,
then our show is,
it's like,
you know,
were in there for two months and then,
uh,
and then we're out and it's done.
And it was this isolated thing.
So I,
I prefer,
I think we both prefer the film pace at this point.
I know.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the,
the advantage of that television,
I agree with him,
but the advantage some will tell you from an actor's point of view that
television has,
is that you can explore a singular character for longer.
If you're doing a long form narrative,
it would be a wonderful thing.
It was,
it was a wonderful thing for Bryan Cranston to be able to be Walter White for
all of that time.
And for him and Vince and the rest of the creative team on that show,
to let Walter grow in different ways and show different facets of his being.
Because when you have a 57 hour movie,
you're just going to have more chance to show,
to show different facets of a human then,
then you can in a movie,
which is why I think movies are harder to write too.
Um,
so I'm just,
that's my one little,
that's my pro for television over cinema.
But,
but you're right in regard to Payson and work,
you just kind of give it your all and it's,
it's,
it comes across as if it's a shortened the sports season.
So you give 110% and then,
and then you're done.
Thank you.
Um,
I'm a boy fan.
Are you now?
I would've never guessed that.
Really.
I've been waiting for a long time.
Um,
I was
wondering,
can you talk about the casting process for Keanu?
Yeah,
we,
you know,
we did it.
Old School.
We had auditions and a lot of catnip,
catnip.
Um,
we,
uh,
as far as the actual cats,
there were three types of cats and we knew we were in for the whole litter when
we,
when we picked them.
Um,
we went with the smoky gray,
smoky gray over the Tuxedo family.
We were going for a dog short,
black hair Tuxedo,
but we didn't pick him as far as Rhonda Clia.
Ironically,
as far as the,
the actors go,
I mean,
method man came in and audition for this movie.
Like,
I mean,
you can imagine like,
you're like,
you know,
like couple of years ago,
you write this movie like,
Eh,
I don't know,
maybe we'll get to do this someday.
He did.
Method man comes in and goes to put down a script,
this improvise,
let's do it.
And He,
you know,
he came in and we literally jumped up and we improvise,
man.
And he's just,
he's holding it down and he's grounded.
He knows,
he knows all his lines enough to jump off and follow us if we're doing different
than,
and he already had the role as far as I skins cern.
Right.
We never had the heart to what,
we were terrified
to tell him that he did not need to audition.
Did not say he's making all the way out here from New York
flight was horrible.
He,
we really want to see what you bring to the table.
Missing teeth
choices you make.
You call it methylamine colon cliff.
We call them we clam cliff.
Did you call him?
We didn't.
He wanted to audition for it.
He,
he,
yeah,
he came in and uh,
we,
the,
the moment we heard that he,
he wanted to audition,
it was like beaming and he's here.
Oh really?
Okay.
Um,
so that was that,
that was super cool.
And then we,
you know,
the,
the gang and this movie,
Tiffany Haddish,
Jason Mitchell,
uh,
Darrell,
Brit Brits,
Gibson,
tomorrow,
neighbors,
our neighbors,
they all auditioned.
And uh,
you know,
each one of them brought this,
this ground.
There's this feeling of reality.
They're kind of like a bad news bears of gangs,
you know,
it's like,
it's the blips,
it's the guys kicked out of the bloods and the crips.
And so there are a little bit,
they're kind of extreme characters,
but at the same time they really,
they ground the thing and make it believable when we're talking to these,
uh,
you know,
the street hardened criminals may,
may make the situation believable.
So they were just,
I mean it's,
it's just such a talented ensemble will forte to who's just,
Oh yeah,
we'll work today.
And he was,
he was kind of,
you know,
I think as soon as we started looking for people,
we went,
oh,
forte is Holka.
He is this character.
Yeah.
So that was,
uh,
that was a no brainer.
He was the easiest.
He was done and then Nia long wanted to come and play.
So that was also a dream come true.
Um,
just very,
very surreal getting to put together this movie out
of like,
people you've admired.
Like I just a mosaic of people that you admire or just opening up a box of
chocolates like,
oh,
that we'll have this one.
Yes.
Yeah,
it was great.
Awesome.
So you guys have touched on this a lot about how building on other ideas is the
basis of escalation,
like the movie and also in the show.
Um,
so as a new improviser it's really easy to trash talk and idea.
So I'm wondering how you build on an India without saying,
oh,
this idea is wrong.
My ideas better.
Um,
the,
the first thing to do is just always know that the rules,
the rules that were established had been established,
have been established for about 70 years.
Um,
when you go,
or even 80 years,
if you go back to Neva Boyd,
never,
Boyd was Islah Spolan Zero and then you have Paul Sills and all the second city
people.
And then,
and then here we have the committee that was here in San Francisco.
So,
so you have to worship the rules above your ego.
And now there's a bunch of different techniques that human being can used to
block ego.
Let,
we can't really go into and do right now.
But,
but that's the most important thing.
Most board things remember really,
really brilliant.
People have been doing this and going about it this way for such a long time.
I mean,
he's like,
my big thing has always been like,
I don't like that idea.
But then they go,
if it was good enough for Mike Nichols and Alan Arkin,
then I guess it's good enough for me.
It,
you know,
so it's because you never know.
You never know what's through that door if you don't open it.
So if their partner,
if your scene partner's shows you the door,
it's not only your job to open it,
it's your job to open it with verve and,
and,
and so that's the thing.
The thing is every mistakes,
a gift and improvisation,
every mistakes,
a gift,
every challenge is an opportunity.
So if you think of it that way,
then know that you're doing the art.
I hate to,
I hate to make it sound scientific,
but you're doing the art correctly.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So don't,
don't worry about your idea.
Might find its way into their idea.
If you just keep yes and yes.
Sandhya sand.
For those of you who don't know what improvisation is,
I've been speaking mandarin for the last two minutes,
but,
but these are,
you know,
but these are life skills,
so it's very,
yeah.
Thank you.
Hey guys.
Hey.
Question about Keanu.
Uh,
when you pick you on you,
did you uh,
did he prefer to be pit with the grain or against the green?
You ain't never met a cat.
Oh Man.
And the cat man.
Any cat?
You got to go with the grant.
We got the one cat in the world.
Talk about fuck my for up.
Toss it up.
Give me a little rush.
No,
no.
Yeah,
we,
we had a bunch of kittens.
They're all,
they're all with grain.
You're all with grand.
Thank you.
Great question.
Hi.
Um,
thanks for coming.
I'm a huge fan since your days on mad TV.
Um,
my question is about the movie title and when you guys were in the creation
process,
uh,
did Kenny Reeves know that you guys are making it and did you guys talk to him?
Do you have a certain reaction every day?
Okay.
We just spoke to him right before you walked in here.
No,
he,
as far as we know,
he's known about it for about a month,
maybe a month and a half.
We,
the trailer since the trailer,
when the red band trailer came out,
his sister saw the trailer and then she sent him a link of the trailer and then
Karen was like,
that's fantastic.
And then I,
and then I read an article,
I don't know,
just say an article this morning.
I read an article this morning that they said that somebody interviewed Keanu
about the move and you said a pair of these,
those guys are wacky.
Can you just can,
I can never even imagine him uttering the word Wacky,
wacky,
and said it several times
in this article.
Like,
like it was like the packages that kind of wacky.
I see.
Those guys are wacky.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Hey,
come on man.
It's the ultimate compliment.
Wacky.
Hey,
um,
so love the anger translator sketches.
Uh,
I was just wondering,
for the White House press correspondence a dinner,
did you get the chance to practice with Obama for a very long time?
Ah,
yeah.
Well I think in his world,
10 minutes is a long time,
so yes,
yes,
I did.
I mean,
you know what I mean,
if given everything he has to do in a day.
So I was in the West Wing and,
and was waiting in a room and the western called the map room,
which is FDR is room.
And there was,
I was staring at this,
this framed map on the wall that FDR had made that,
uh,
about where the allied troops were going to land and all this kind of,
if it was really amazing.
And then on the wall,
just racks and racks and racks of maps from,
from the thirties back ad infinitum.
And um,
and then he just walks in and he's a very tactile guy.
And so he's just,
you know,
you just kind of there and he's just on you.
Just this,
like whenever he goes,
let's go,
hey,
let's call him mister president.
And then you're just like,
I didn't hug him.
He did it.
No red dots please.
He ran up up in here.
He just ran up on me in here,
rehearsed
and we rehearsed for about 10 minutes.
And then they,
uh,
and then they left and,
and you know,
and the first thing he said to me was,
was that you'll get,
we're going to go through this now and you have to really,
you know,
gotta keep it together.
We've got to keep it together.
I was like,
yes sir.
Absolutely.
So he says his first line,
which is,
you know,
so I thought that I would,
if you remember his first line of something,
like I thought I would,
and he's reading off this script and he goes,
I thought I'd bring out my anger translator Luther.
And then my first line is,
hold on to your lily white.
But yeah,
we're two lines into the rehearsal.
And he goes,
oh
right,
I got to keep it together.
Yeah,
yeah.
Mother fucker.
You got to keep it together.
Your career is locked in.
This could be the biggest day of my life.
Don't fuck it up,
you know?
Okay.
It was great.
No,
he was great.
What a amazing straight man.
And,
and he was terrific
because at the end he just was like,
the last thing he said to me before we finished the,
the rehearsal was he just kept on asking about Jordan,
which I thought was so sweet.
And he was just like,
yeah,
how's bill feel about it?
And I was so,
he was,
he was great and he just kept asking about him.
So it was,
it was terrific.
He's really,
it's like you can't have a better fan,
you know,
can have a better fan.
It's,
and not about who he is in the world so much as a person that you were doing
homage to them and they know about it.
And then this,
this character gets to become,
I don't know that this has ever happened in the history of television that I
don't even know how to articulate it correctly.
That a fictional character with a person doing in precision becomes a real tool
in the real world.
It's,
it's,
it's mind boggling because he used Luther,
he literally used Luther cause he's like the campfire me,
fuck it.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it was amazing.
It was really quite amazing.
Yeah.
Cool.
Thank you.
We can do these quick.
Okay.
A,
um,
when you guys are writing,
I do you find that,
um,
you cycled through hundreds of ideas until you go,
that's the one,
that's what we're going with or is it,
you have some that you're not sure about but you try it out and then saying and
then eventually working into something that's really good.
Okay.
We definitely overwrite,
we come up with a lot of premises.
We write a lot of drafts and uh,
so,
so that at the end of the day,
you know,
when,
when you get to that point where you're like,
oh man,
we can only afford one more sketch and this episode,
no,
as far as people,
you're welcome.
How's it knows smart.
Thank you.
Woo.
Yes.
Sorry about that.
But yes,
to answer
question,
we,
we write,
we write a ton and then,
uh,
we,
we only pick the cream of the crop.
Um,
I kittens and I've learned two things.
One,
they grow up extremely quickly and two,
they have no sense for ever doing what you want.
Like were there moments where you regretted the choice of having a cat in the
movie?
Absolutely.
And,
and,
and we had two sets of kittens.
We,
yeah,
one day literally reached into the thing with like Grossberg done,
we're using teddy.
You know what I mean?
It was like,
yeah,
eventually you have to figure out,
you have to figure out to tell the kitten to do something you don't want it to
do.
And then,
then,
and only then will you get the shot.
You were actually looking for.
But yeah,
very,
very tricky.
And,
and you don't think about that.
You think it's just a prop.
It's another,
it's another actor.
You have to be mindful of.
I don't gentlemen.
Hey,
how's it going?
What's happening?
Can you mentioned you about to do theater now or start moving towards that?
Are there any artists that we need to look for a,
that you're mentoring or any pro pro djs out there that we need to be able to
look out for?
Anyone that's come to you and said,
hey,
look out for this guy.
He's going to be the hint hint.
I see what you did then.
Yeah.
Do you want to knows big care?
Know this brother that I saw it
Google
and he wasn't afraid to ask for what he wanted
to be nice cap had on a t shirt with a colloquialism mountain.
Um,
it's something that I know Jordan,
I have both been approached with our reps about is,
is curating or help curating and,
and mentoring other artists.
And,
um,
and so I'm kind of in the process of doing that now,
but it's,
we've been so busy,
I've not had the time to dedicate to looking at people's work.
And,
um,
there is a group of guys that I like a lot that are on comedy central that and
Kumi central.com and they have a web series right now called um,
uh,
six guys,
one car.
And it's amazing because they're African American sketch guys,
but they're not trained at the upright citizens brigade.
They're not trained at second city.
They're not treated Improv Olympic,
but they have an aesthetic that's close to our training and I'm really
fascinated by them.
And so I may or may not work with them in the future.
I'm trying to figure out where I fit or how it can benefit them.
And um,
and,
and that,
is there something I,
that I really do want to do more in the future?
It's,
it is,
it's near and dear to my heart.
And,
and it is to Jordan too.
It's,
it's been a big thing for us to want to,
to mentor a Young African Americans who want to get into improvisation.
Thank you.
All right,
last question.
Dang it.
I'm up there.
Come on.
[inaudible].
You see crowd,
this is good.
As a very positive group.
My own opinion on this boat,
which of you makes the better looking woman?
It's Jordan.
100% well,
now you know it's,
look at these luscious lips.
It's debatable.
I mean,
we have different assets.
Yeah.
Is it is.
Mine is here.
Keegan's a figure is,
but I lacked curves.
I don't have child bearing years.
We can debate this all day,
but,
but you're,
you're a bit Meagan.
Seriously,
not seriously.
I am saying seriously.
Shut your mouth
and I like Thai tea right now.
Who are you going to get home?
Meagan?
Why?
You're going to walk through seven miles,
one foot in front of the other.
How are you?
How are you going to get home?
I'm going to drive in this fucking automobile.
More power.
Tea.
Yeah.
You were complaining about your shoes.
No.
Yes.
You were
wasting the Google People's time.
You're going to screw the status.
Gosh,
you're going to get a question.
Alright sweetheart,
you agree with me,
right,
right.
It's him.
But Hey,
you know what is him?
He's right.
That it's debatable.
It's debatable.
Debatable.
How was your opinion?
Is that it was debatable.
You did start with,
I have an opinion.
I know my definite opinion about this.
I'll either one.
I will unveil it at the end of this question.
I was hoping for Megan.
All right,
sorry my brother.
You know a lot of lot hottest shenanigans.
Yep.
At your expense.
Now I feel weird because I was going to ask a serious question and,
all right.
Uh,
so you guys talk a lot about a race.
It feels like that that's what a big part of what your comedy is about.
That's what I really like about it.
Uh,
do you bring that to Kiana?
Where are you trying to say let's focus more on just making a movie.
That's like what you said before.
Just funny.
Like this kind of style of,
this is a bad question.
No,
it's good.
It's not a bad question cause
I,
I will say this and this is something I think I've,
I haven't said in a while,
but I do believe that it has validity if you have melanin in your skin.
The movie's about race because we just don't live in a world.
That's it.
That evolved yet.
You know what I mean?
Because I beat because our,
I'm not going to do it.
I'm going to do it because our limb,
because we still have a limbic system,
we're still categorizing because remember we remember when we had to categorize,
that's a saber tooth tiger.
That's a poisonous plant.
This is wheat.
And so the limbic system worked.
It was effective and now we use it.
Now we use it for the wrong reasons.
You know,
we go,
that's different than me.
Must be bad.
And so until,
until we find a way to short circuit that fight or flight lizard brain part of
us,
I think if you are a person of color,
it just is about race.
Whether you won.
Now in this film,
I do think we still,
we're deliberately sending up stereotypes,
social and cultural stereotypes.
100% with consciousness.
Absolutely.
I mean,
this,
the satirical element of this,
of this movie is that,
you know,
we haven't seen guys like us as leads of a,
of a film.
And so part of that is asking the question about the stereotypes of black men of
Hispanic men have and women in,
in movies up until now.
And what happens when we place ourselves in one of these heightened genres?
And we're definitely lampooning the concept of machismo.
Yeah.
And then we'll be yes.
And what place it has in,
um,
African American culture and in just a culture of being a male.
And Are you black if you don't display a lot of machismo?
Are you black?
Eh,
how black are you if you,
you know,
it's that,
it's,
that's all being explored.
So,
yeah.
Yeah.
Fantastic question.
Thank you.
Well done.
[inaudible].
Thank you guys so much for being here.
Kiano comes out April 29 to go see it.
April 29.
Thank you guys.
Please.
That's it.